US Secretary of State has voiced
concerns over turkeys increasingly close
relationship with Russia speaking on a
radio show Mike Pompeo cast doubt over
whether Turkey can continue as a member
of NATO almost 67 years in the Alliance
does there come a moment where Turkey's
future as a NATO nation and as an ally
comes into question I hope not
it would be unfortunate for NATO it'd be
unfortunate for the United States and I
think even more unfortunate for the
people of Turkey if if that were to
become the case we are hopeful that
turkey and president Rome will come to
understand the u.s. is a better partner
than Iran and the direction that the
president want octa Co is to support
deeper relationships with the United
States and with Europe and with NATO
Turkey's relationship with the US and
the rest of NATO has been strained by a
series of disputes they include u.s.
support for Kurdish forces in Syria who
are considered by Turkey to be
terrorists meanwhile Turkey's recent
efforts to coordinate with Iran and
Russia in Syria have angered Washington
the u.s. still refuses to hand over
dissident cleric Fethullah Gulen who
turkey blames for an attempted coup in
2016 and NATO has been urging Turkey to
scrap the purchase of a Russian
anti-missile system alessandro bruno
senior analyst at Lombardi letter
believes u.s. foreign policy is putting
a strain on NATO I don't think mr.
Pompeo really believes his own words
there he knows more better than anyone
in right now that Turkey could have
plenty of incentives to leave NATO the
one who would lose the most unlike what
mr. Pompeo said is not the people of
Turkey rather it is the United States
they would lose people I would say that
Turkey is the most fundamental country
right now the United States is just
putting too much pressure
on its allies to act in ways that its
are not in his allies interest the way
they do it one right now it seems to be
only against the interest of what it's
giving all the tie line not just Turkey
very good reasons to leave rather than
to stay
you